bueno muchas gracias por tenerme en el
programa yo diría que primero hay que
tomar las palabras del presidente de
bayern como lo que él tiene como su
intención él tiene que limpiar la mesa
de todo lo que ha quedado pendiente
durante los últimos cinco años
por parte de rusia que durante el
período es el presidente de trump hay
temas internos hay temas externos y hay
que ser muy claros que cuando rusia
interfiere en este tipo de cosas hay un
precio que pagar tenemos el caso de
naval ni del melanoma miento y la
prisión de naval de y tenemos ucrania y
crimea tenemos interferencia en dos
selecciones estadounidenses tenemos
saqueo en los sistemas de el gobierno
estadounidense
tenemos las recompensas que rusia
ofreció para el asesinato de tropas
estadounidenses en el exterior así que
estas son cosas que hay que tratarlas
y sacarlas de la mesa para que el
presidente de byn pueda establecer una
nueva relación entre adultos entre él y
el señor putin como líderes maduros que
tienen cosas que hacer él ha ofreció una
cumbre con el presidente putin uno a uno
en europa no requirió que viniese a los
eeuu
quieres establecer una relación madura
entre los líderes internacionales para
que puedan comenzar a tomar temas serios
que tienen entre los dos países y temas
sobre el la proliferación nuclear iran
corea hay muchas cosas que deben estar
tiendo en vez de estar peleando y es que
precisamente el presidente de bailén
afirmó que sostuvo una conversación
franca con vladimir putin y asegura
querer una relación estable como tú como
con moscú como usted bien lo decida sin
embargo hace pocas semanas llamaba
asesinó al presidente ruso le pregunto
si entonces están las relaciones entre
los dos países en su peor momento
no yo creo que no yo creo que es lo que
el presidente bailarín quiere hacer es
que tengamos una relación madura entre
poderes para poder tratar temas que
tenemos en común que son importantes no
solamente para cada país sino también
para el mundo y bajo la situación que
existe estamos jugando juegos rusia ha
estado haciendo cosas porque el señor
trump dejaba que se ocurre creo que
ocurriesen ahora va a índices y nos van
a pegar van a tener que sufrir pero
creemos que es mejor restablecer una
base
esto limpia la mesa de estos temas
pendientes y podemos recomenzar señor
colegio gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés 24con en que usted
una feliz resto de noche